Donald Trump appears to have turned off, uh,
a Fox News, uh, literally, um, and also turned
on Fox News figuratively turned against them
so to speak, at least weekend Fox News. And
he has unleashed exactly the type of unhinged
Twitter storm that we've become pretty used
to actually, if something that the president
does over the last couple of years. Remember
I told you before, there's nothing immutable
or set in stone about Fox News and Donald
Trump being aligned?
Yes. Right now, Trump mostly is watching fox
news. Trump mostly says that Fox news is doing
the right type of, of reporting a Fox give
Trump a lot of ideas that then Trump sees
on Fox and friends in the morning and then
tweets about all day or talks about for a
few days. On the other hand, yes, mostly Fox
News supports Donald Trump. Sometimes Shepard
Smith or Chris Wallace will say some basic
uncontroversial truth, uh, you know, fundamental
real-world critique of Donald Trump and the
fox news audience will be angry with them
even though in most of the world, what Fox
and what Shep and Chris Wallace say is just
the truth. But remember that early in the
2016 Republican Primary Fox News and Donald
Trump are not actually aligned and they only
later sort of joined forces. Anyway, Trump
is furious. Check out this series of tweets
and as usual, imagine Barack Obama sitting
around tweeting stuff like this. It's hard
to imagine because it would never have happened
because this is unlike anything we've ever
seen before in the Oval Office.
Trump tweeting quote, watching Fox News weekend
anchors is worse than watching low ratings,
fake news, CNN or Lyon. Brian Williams. Remember
when he totally fabricated a war story, trying
to make himself into a hero and got fired,
a very dishonest journalist and the crew of
degenerate. Comcast, NBC, MSNBC, Trump haters
who do whatever Brian and Steve Tell them
to do like CNN. NBC is also way down in the
ratings, but Fox News who failed in getting
the very boring dem debates is now loading
up with Democrats and even using fake unsourced
New York Times as a source of information.
Ask The Times what they paid for the Boston
Globe and what they sold it for. Lost one
point $5 billion or their old headquarters
building disaster or they're unfunded liability.
Fox News is changing fast, but they forgot
the people who got them there. This thing
about, they forgot that people who got them
there, Trump seems to have the relationship
backwards.
They got Trump there by jumping on his side
about halfway through the 2016 campaign when
they saw that he actually seemed to be appealing
to a shockingly high portion of the Republican
electorate and they kind of work together
in getting Trump to where he is today. Now,
all of this happened. Why? It's not really
clear. We don't know. Um, it appears that
it might be because Fox news broadcast the
following video of people in France watching
the women's World Cup final and when Fox News
goes live, the crowd knows it's Fox News and
they start chanting f Trump. Take a look at
this video.
Mystery has just been made. Art Thou, we are
here in a sports bar in Leon France. Here,
listen to it. We're in a sports bar. We were
going to be outside. We were going to be looking
at a screen [inaudible] football. Just
the funniest part about this is that if this
really is why Trump lost it on Fox News, it's
not really Fox's fault. I mean Fox is doing
live TV. This is what people started chanting,
presumably unbeknownst to the anchor as he
went live. But if this makes Trump angry with
fox, great, because any disruption to Fox
being a total arm of the Trump administration
status quo is great. And Trump continuing
his bizarre attack on Fox later on, saying,
quote, impossible to believe that Fox News
has hired Donna Brazil, the person fired by
CNN after they tried to hide the bad facts
and failed forgiving crooked Hillary Clinton
the questions to a debate, something unimaginable.
Now she is all over Fox, including Shep Smith
by far their lowest rated show. Watch the
Fox News weekend. Daytime anchors who are
terrible go after her big time. That's what
they want. But it sure is not what the audience
wants.
I don't really know that a super deep analysis
is even required here. I mean, Trump is triggered
because he expects Fox News to be pro Trump
echo chambers 24, seven occasionally, sometimes
even by accident. In the case of that video,
uh, from the, uh, World Cup, uh, Paris f Trump
champ something, we'll occasionally pierce
the echo chamber and Donald Trump gets mad.
This guy, a very sensitive snowflake. He constantly
attacks others as weak soldiers who have PTSD
or not strong enough. Uh, even though Trump's
dad paid a doctor to write a letter about
how Trump's ankles preclude him from going
to Vietnam, totally emasculated is Trump by
the mere mention of John McCain. So he makes
it his job to attack McCain endlessly. And
the most important implication is that if
the relationship between Trump and Fox News
breaks as the 2020 election gets closer, that's
a really good opportunity for something other
than Fox News, uh, um, uh, to be preventing
to get into the action.
And maybe we can get Trump, uh, removed from
office in the sense that anything that disrupts
this kind of hand in glove relationship between
Trump and Fox News is great and we should
make sure to publicize anytime that there
is this apparent riff. When Fox criticizes
Trump, it should be widely publicized. We
know Trump will hear about it. We know it
will trigger him, we know it will send them
into another Twitter frenzy and anything we
can do to sever that relationship is potentially
going to pay dividends in the 2020 election.
Now, just as a word of warning, remember if
Trump moves on from Fox as his favorite, he
is probably going to move on to promoting
an even crazier channel called [inaudible].
I don't remember if it's o a n or o a. N N.
I think it's like one America news or the
one American news network. I forget exactly.
It's even more off the deep end than Fox News
if you can imagine it and check it out online
if you want. Although you may not be thrilled
about giving them a, any of your a web traffic
and potentially ad revenue. But if Trump does
sever the tie with Fox, he's probably going
to OAN and they're even wackier and OAN rising
in terms of prominence in the United States
would be materially destructive to everything
we hold near and dear in terms of the fabric
of this country. So there's ups and downs,
I dunno. What do you think is going on with
the Trump fox relationship? Uh, let me know.